this is the West reserves this is the
West
Reserve from the Los Angeles Clippers
Kawai Leonard yes indeed his sixth
Allstar selection uh for the claw um 24
points a night six rebounds four assists
shooting 52% which is a career high for
Kawhi Leonard had 11 games of 30 points
this year and Clippers of been rolling
31 and 15 the number three team in the
west and we're talking all this about
injuries and things he should be in the
MVP
conversation because they I think they
going to finish with the best record in
the west could be he's played in 41 of
their 46 games by the way okay you still
got the
ball from the Los Angeles Lakers Anthony
Davis ad as we told you as we came on
the air will not play tonight because of
injury neither he nor LeBron will be but
now this is nine Allstar Selections in
his 12th season he had made eight
straight from 2014 to 21 hasn't made it
since 25 points a game is number 17 12
rebounds a game is number four two and a
half blocks a game is number five so
Anthony Davis um is a reserve for the
Western Conference jet you're up I'm
up in the West from the Phoenix Suns
Devin Booker his uh fourth All-Star
selection this is season number nine for
book well deserved 28 points a game
sixth in the league five rebounds seven
assists which is number 10 in the league
shooting 50% and 39% from Deep he's had
15 games of 35 games of 40 and had 62 at
Indiana so Devin Booker uh is a Western
Conference Allstar all right I'm the
third person only to know
this but from the Minnesota timber
wolves Anthony Edwards Anthony Edwards
for the team with the best record in the
Western Conference Minnesota's 34 and 14
he's an Allstar for the second time in
his fourth season 25 points a game is
number 15 five rebounds five assists
he's played in 45 of their 48 games
games and uh 17 games of at least 30
points including a 44o effort against
the Phoenix Sun so those are four and
here is number five I don't even need to
read it cuz I'm psychic this one
probably says Stephan Curry check my
work Ernie please sir can't you just do
this the regular way man I just want to
make
sure yeah he I did not Steph Curry
you're right it is Stephen Curry it is
well done I wish I had have been
somebody else
carac look you don't know what's going
on while the videos rolling anyway Steph
10 time Allstar now uh eighth in the
league and scoring with 27 tonight four
rebounds and five assists and
uh golden state has struggled but Steph
continues to make it look Steph
effortless okay and from the Los Angeles
Clippers Paul George Paul George joining
kawh Leonard as a reserve in the Western
Conference um ninth time that he's an
Allstar 14 seasons in the league 23
points a night five rebounds three
assists played in 43 of their 46 games
seven games of at least 30 points and so
again for those Clippers who are 31 and
15 and number three in the west Paul
George is a final one this is the final
this is big this is the final card that
are eligible Western Conference yes
indeed they put I'm just going to I'm
going to actually open the card and then
read it and not try any of that I
already know who it is AR here it is I I
think okay final Reserve Western
Conference from the Minesota
Timberwolves Carl
anony best record uh in the western
conference for the Minnesota
Timberwolves and he joins his teammate
Anthony
Edwards um on this team Carl Anthony
towns fourth time he's been an Allstar
23 points nine rebounds which is number
18 in the league shooting 52% and a
career-high 44% from Deep uh four games
of at least 30 points and that's 62
against Charlotte and so that completes
the Western Conference reserves and oh
you want me to read them now yes no just
want you to just keep it over there no
put it on your forehead and guess the
Eastern Conference Reserve serves here
we go all righty
then from the Boston Celtics Jaylen
Brown oh he made it easy third time an
Allstar in his eighth season for the C's
who had the best record in the biz 37
and 11 23 points a night five rebounds
four assists shooting
49% 10 games of 30 with a high of 40 and
Jaylen Brown joining Jason t him as all
star for the Eastern Conference oh
here's another one for you put in I I no
but this is a big moment for these guys
he said the wrong name somebody be
jumping up and down they're like oh
sorry my
bad from the Cleveland Cavaliers Donovan
Mitchell yes indeed another uh as
expected I would uh the Cavaliers on
fire right now yes indeed um they're 29
and 16 fourth in the East and oh the
Nicks not 28 which is number seven in
the league five rebounds six assists 15
games of 30 plus four games of 40 plus
and an Allstar for the fifth time here
Kenny are your two cards thank you sir
see how you just give adult give adults
two cards instead of
one I can trust him to play this fairly
straight oh I was hoping I got this one
from the New York Knicks Jaylen Brunson
by way The Chicago Kid that's Chicago
now in New Yorker first Allstar
appearance in his sixth season I was
hoping I got that one 12th in the league
and scoring with 27 four rebounds six
assist which is number 14 he's played in
46 of their 48 games 18 games of 30 plus
he's had four of 40 plus and had a 50
piece at Phoenix and should be in the
MVP conversation yeah and so Jaylen BR
so now you have to go to Allstar Weekend
Jay going
I so pops we did it for the first time
good for him man well deserved did it oh
man this is o
oh good
one from the Miami Heat bam out of B his
third Allstar selection in his seventh
season for bam who's given the heat 21
points and 10 rebounds which is number
eight in the league four assists he's
shooting
50% uh couple of games of 30 yeah he's
played well um he's had a triple double
and
um the heat 25 and 23 sitting at the
number seven spot in the Eastern
Conference so congratulations to Bam
adabo who was again an Allstar couple of
cards for the chuckster thank
you I like this suspense I do
too
wow and I like a wow too from the New
York Knicks Julius Randall that's not a
wow Julius Randle not a wild the dudes
is on fire yeah they he hadn't playing
fool yeah he played the last two games
man he been playing the whole year he's
played 46 out of 48 he played 46 out of
48 games 24 point tonight nine rebounds
five assists he is out right now with a
dislocated shoulder which will probably
open up a spot for the commissioner uh
to fill but Julius Randall joining
Jaylen Brunson on the Eastern conf well
deserved Stars yes what
question well this is going to be great
for me for my Philadelphia
76ers Tyrese Maxi another another first
timer love to see it man yeah wow that's
big hard work pays off Breeze y fourth
season in the league first time Allstar
26 points a night number 14 four
rebounds seven assists which is number
13 12 games of 30 plus two games of 40
plus he threw 50 at Indiana one night
and um you know what the players when
they voted had him starting um he was
number two in in the player vote uh but
he is a reserve he was number two in the
player vote Hal was number one correct
right okay right yeah they had it Hal
and that's the right way it should have
been as the starters yeah so there you
go want one more that's that's that's
tough Hy this is it no this
is because I know I know there are a few
guys hanging on and that's all I meant
about Julius Randle I like Julius Randle
but it's it's these last couple were
tough hey could I read this yes
no from the Orlando Magic Paulo banero
yes rounds out the Eastern Conference
All
Stars Paulo vano was the number one pick
in 22 the 23 Rookie of the Year 23
points a night seven rebounds five
assists all those career highs eight
games of 30 plus points two games of 40
plus and Hollow B Caro congratulations
man again seeing these first timers that
is that's really cool to see the first
time you well deserved the first time
you make it it's the best time I mean I
mean I'm just happy for these guys man
it's and this never gets old being
selected an allar no matter how many
times it's an honor and a
privilege